how do you know this brother here is
serious about you how would you know how
would you how would you say you know
what this guy trying to do
yeah
the reason you guys say that is because
maybe you had bad experience yeah yeah a
girl says you know what if you like me
you gotta come and speak to my father
oh no no no no no it's not the money I
have the man I would I would go to the
father and he would have someone if she
said to you you gotta come speak to my
brother how would you feel
[Music]
today we are out in Shepherd's Bush and
it's Valentine's Day as you guys know as
Muslims we are not allowed to date and
we go about things the right way we go
to the father so what we're going to do
today is we're gonna pop this bubble and
ask people what they think about the
Muslim way of getting to know somebody
and the dangers of her own relationships
we're gonna find that now sometimes they
have you guys do you have boyfriends
yeah no you don't okay all right so how
would you suss out so when you met your
boyfriend how did you know this guy is
genuine or he's a player how did you
know
you just don't think you just hold your
cars close to your chest and then just
wait and see that was my mistake it was
my mistake okay what do you mean by a
hold like you just keep keep the guard
up a little bit and then see how it goes
and then if they're genuine it'll come
through like I've had friends before
yeah who are like the players and stuff
kind of stuff yeah yeah and they see a
lot of young boys are yes yes yeah
that's what they say men are yes trash
yes exactly yeah exactly the reason you
guys see that is because maybe you had
bad experience yeah yeah yeah what's
your name David David and Sister Sarah
Sarah okay he said that there might be a
potential that you guys might go out Etc
okay
you know they finished the sentence of
men are trash okay how do you saw
someone else the way he talks to like if
he respects you okay if you respect you
see in the way that he looks at you and
stuff like that or the way that he likes
language yeah
okay so even if I'm in a WhatsApp
conversation or saying the brother has
to be there and
and your girlfriend
hello hello
okay so basically I'm a Muslim yeah I'm
Orthodox Muslim let me put it like this
here okay
how do you know it's a question to you
sister how do you know he really loves
you
but how would you know if he really
loves you and he's after the wrong
things how would you start
because he's been with me for two years
like okay so you've been together two
years yeah if you guys get married
okay how do you know
this brother here
is serious about you
how would you know how would you how
would you say you know what so now if
you really love a girl yeah okay I love
my girlfriend
means you gotta do it the right way yeah
now
if you want to get to this imagine you
like this girl okay yeah when you grow
up how old are you
12 11 yeah so when you're when you're
16. when you're 16 yeah okay it doesn't
matter 11 12 same thing here so when you
grow up here imagine this girl says you
know what if you like me you gotta come
and speak to my father
all right
now this is fake love it's fake exactly
like older like whoa yeah
if somebody's after the wrong intentions
here for the wrong reasons
he's not going to come to you looking
but he's not gonna act me you get to
know her obviously in that process
you're a man she's a woman do you have
desires yeah things happen yeah and then
what if you turn around and say
you're not the one for me
what if I do that yeah yeah you can
isn't it yeah yeah that can happen yeah
so then you're just going to casually
tell her like sorry you know it's not
meant to be
yeah 100 okay I'm gonna talk in general
in general in general I don't know like
if you've got good more rules yeah if
you like I don't know if you're smart
not on this writing okay you know yeah
if you're a nice person not just trying
to be an delete girls okay I'm got
respected we've got respect in that yeah
okay all right [ __ ] you know what how
men go about things how would you know
if he's a player or not coming from a
man's perspective can you can you sus
can a girl suss a man out a play or not
or is it hard
is it
that's after the wrong thing
as a male
who do you go about things like is he
gonna he's not gonna make him so big so
can a female suss out a guy being
genuine I don't know that I don't know
I had friends back in the day yeah yeah
they're about messing around
unless it unless he gets caught up yeah
I don't really think like a clock unless
he makes it bait so if you don't make it
big they would never know until they put
themselves in that situation
yo this guy's a Jew hold on a second you
will go to the father and see what they
have to say
if I go to the father and see what they
have to say if you're gonna say silly
things then obviously I'm gonna go yes
if you had a daughter and some man
didn't come to you and went behind your
back and start dating that's true that's
true that's true but like I'll see if if
you have to go you have to go to my
daughter to do these rules so you don't
like that Reaper anything like that can
a girl tell the difference between a
player and not a player
be honest
I don't think so I think so it's a trick
that these men have you know that you
know they can't be spotted you know
what's the camouflage what's the
camouflage I can't I can't tell you that
one but you just take it it's a secret
yeah it's a secret like I don't know man
it's different and if she said to you
you gotta come speak to my brother how
would you feel
no no I get you that I'll fool that I
feel all that she's obviously respecting
the team and if I respect her as well if
that's what she grants then I'll do it
in it this guy's a good boy so you need
to you need to keep this quote and get
married and come with your wedding but
but if if a man's a player and if the
girl says meet my brother what would he
do
she said come and speak to my dad
stay away yeah she said she said look
you interested in me come speak to my
dad what would you say I'll say not
right now I can't do that right now okay
so now islamically how we day and how we
get married it's a bit different yeah so
I wanted to share that with you guys and
I just wanted your feedback okay okay I
think I might know it already Okay so
okay we're gonna take a guess is it it's
not like you go through your parents do
you kind of like get your parents to
kind of suggest yes so basically like
suitors let's suppose let's say I'm
interested in a female yeah I will have
to go to her father and say I'm
interested in your daughter I would like
to get to know her
today are you you can right but there's
restrictions yeah it's regulated yeah
but the reason is regulating which I'm
going to come to in a minute yeah is
because when I'm getting to know her her
brother her father has to be in the room
so they don't it doesn't have to be like
there and like right as you're speaking
but he has to you know see what's going
on yeah okay because obviously you know
gender female males they have you know
kind of desires so now
how do you think that is compared to in
our society for example let me give you
guys some stats here
400 000 people carry STDs yeah you have
a chance of getting raped you have a
chance of being your hop you're getting
your heart broken yeah because if you
meet and they say you meet some guy yeah
he's gonna he's not gonna tell you he's
a rapist or he's a player he's going to
tell you everything you want to hear so
based on the honest reply yeah
the way we go about it would you not say
it's a more of a way where it secures
the interest of a female and as I'm
getting to know her the father or the
brother has to be prison yeah what what
do you think about that
[Music]
do you not think it takes it's there to
secure the female's interest because you
know some men after the wrong things you
get me against because we also have this
concept called the female can ask for
something called mother so what that
means is if I'm proposing to you you can
say okay as a matter that's a gift I
want five grand
yeah so
if I'm after the wrong things I'm not
gonna pay five grand yeah I'm trying to
say so
the perfect people have told us that
when a man and a woman is alone the
third person is Satan yeah this would
believe insane what that means is desire
is my kicking and something might happen
so Islam if you're going to the cinema
right okay so we have this concept
called prevention is better than cure
yeah so that's the reason why what it
does is it says the brother has to be
there you know why because a man knows a
man I'm a man if I know some man if I
talk to him and you can tell and another
thing is if he's after the wrong thing
he's not going to want to meet me but
that's about it really it's just there
to secure the the interest of the female
so so then we don't call men trash
anymore even though some of them are you
say that's a good method or not
yeah it's a good yeah yeah it's a good
method I think so you would appreciate
him or be honest with me but if a man
came and said look I'm interested in you
I want to speak to your father and go
about the right way do not say you know
what no that would be impressive
so if he if he was like coming up to me
and just like listen I really like you I
want to get to know you but I'm going to
see if it's okay with your dad first
that's that's like oh okay so you
actually want to be serious about it
yeah what do you think I just want you
as are you Muslims
okay so as as a non-muslim that system
what do you say about what do you think
about imagine if you're the daughter
yeah would you would you want that to be
implemented though so if a guy wanted to
marry a daughter for him to come to you
or would you say I just want your honest
feedback no I don't want him to come to
me and I ask for my like permission and
yeah yeah you you prefer that yeah yeah
well I always agree with that the
Muslims yes you have to ask for the
follow us for this year that's what I'm
talking about see as Muslims here well
the reason we're doing this is because
islamically if I love somebody I have to
go and approach their father so you know
why so then if I'm messing around I
wouldn't approach your father in it
because I've got bad intentions but if I
got good intentions I would meet I don't
mind meeting her father I'm trying to
say and that's what we're trying to see
if that's the right way to go about it
look at the camera and say keep it halal
okay guys so we've just spoken to the
people who
can see now that show
we putting jokes aside and all these
kind of things aside obviously he was
trying to you know get a bit abandon
with the people and stuff like that but
when job society and this is this is
actually a serious matter you know so if
you think about it we asked them and um
most of them said you know what they
actually appreciate and value the
Islamic way of getting to know somebody
in the right way yeah now that says a
lot you know why because most of the
time it's coming from experience a lot
of the time females majority of the time
females and I know there's a lot of
female conflicts as well but a lot of
the time females are the ones that are
suffering they're the ones who get the
end of the stick I'm trying to say and
they're suffering and because because of
the most of the females that we went and
said men are they finish off with trash
why because they've had this bad
experience and why do you have this bad
experience because if you do not have
something that's regulating that's being
sent down or any kind of regulation in
place what's gonna happen is you're
going to have males who are there who's
going to mess you around he's going to
mess around with you who's going to come
to you and say yeah I want to marry you
going to give you these false promises
and afterwards what's going to happen
boom they're going to leave you they're
going to go to move on and that's the
reason this phrase meant our trash is
used why because a lot of females have
suffered this and they've seen how they
get messed around they get used around
they get abused and what does a man do
he says I'm moving on now and all he has
to do is grow a beard wear a fob or
whatever it may be the story is done for
him but at the end of the females
they're the ones who suffer so brothers
and sisters very clear Allah says do not
even come close to Zina so with this you
can see the people who are living it and
telling you the negative side of it I'm
trying to say and whatever Allah is
legislative it's for your own benefit
and you heard it for yourself your
Muslim heard it for yourself even the
men that said nah nah nah you know when
he said okay but wait for your daughter
when his daughter came into the equation
when his sister comes into the equation
his auntie his mom his wife it's a
different story and brothers and sisters
in my marriage documentary inshallah
that's exactly what I'll be showing you
guys because this is just like you might
see this as like you know little banter
thing but then they what I live through
I've had people close to me kill
theirself I've had my cousin hang
himself I've had his friend hang himself
I had my neighbor kill himself in my
documentary we're gonna go and delve
into this matter and see the destruction
that lies behind it
and also we're going to be speaking in
my marriage documentary inshallah
speaking to a female who her life is
destroyed she was on the verge of
committing suicide why because she got
messed around for five years five years
she got messed around when she went to
the guy's house the solder get lost just
like she goes I feel like an absolute
trash you're gonna see that in my
marriage documentary and also also the
reason I'm saying this as well it's me
personally and I'm only sharing this
with you guys so you benefit in my
jahili I was involved in her own
relationships yeah and we go
10 years back we go three to about 200
miles away to a place that I used to
live and I was involved in a Haram
relationship yeah and we go there and we
speak to my friends who are involved in
Haram relationships and we even go and
speak to the mom the mother of the girl
that was in that relationship with
alhamdulillah protected me from anything
uh major alhamdulillah but we're gonna
go there and find out and learn
inshallah the damages the destruction
relationships cause brothers and sisters
do not learn it the hard way Islam says
prevention is better than cure there is
no point you're getting into this and
they're looking for cure okay what's the
medicine don't even go close to it
hope you guys have benefited share this
with your friends and family inshallah
Mary's document is gonna be a very soon
inshallah and it's going to change the
way you go about things inshallah and
you will learn from my story and my
mistakes not to commit the same things
may Allah bless you guys for watching
hope you guys enjoyed it share it with
your friends and family till next time